hi everyone its Johanna here you're
watching this video because you want to
start losing weight but you just do not
know where is the starting point so what
I want to share with you today are seven
simple steps to kickstart a successful
weight loss journey before you can go on
to a successful weight loss journey you
have to find your inner motivation and
that is the first step so ask yourself
what is your inner motivation that makes
you so desperately want to lose the
weight if your answer is because I am
overweight that is not enough you have
to dig deeper so for instance my wedding
is coming up in six months I've got a
graduation coming up in six months or do
you have a certain health issue that you
need to deal with or a confidence issue
that you are overcoming or even is your
weight preventing you from getting a
certain job so be honest and ask
yourself what is your inner motivation
because this is your key to give you the
strength to see through the weight loss
journey if your reason is merely
physical appearance or to look like a
certain celebrity I would suggest that
you really ate your goal because this
can lead to an unhealthy obsession both
physically and mentally hence I always
emphasize the importance of loving and
accepting yourself before you can make
any changes we are all different
beautiful in our own ways and we should
start embracing that once you have found
your inner motivation write it down
because this is your key to success next
is to do a give-and-take list we cannot
expect to lose the weight without making
any sacrifices or changes to your
current lifestyle so the gift list is to
weigh out what will you gain from losing
weight for instance to learn your dream
job better health more confidence
happier and more energy whereas the take
list will be what sacrifices or changes
do you need to make for instance getting
up thirty minutes
every day to do your workout or no more
late-night snacks last fried food more
home-cooked meals and reduce on your
alcohol consumption so once you have
written your give-and-take list weigh in
the balance make sure that it's really
stick to your schedule and your
lifestyle and consciously tell yourself
that you are ready to commit to these
positive lifestyle changes with this
there should not be any more excuses
through your weight loss journey the
second step is to set a SMART goal your
goal has to be specific measurable
attainable realistic and time-bound do
not expect to lose 10 kilos in two weeks
you did not put all the weight overnight
hands it will take time to lose the
weight as well so if you are ready to
invest your time and effort into this
and to stop looking for shortcuts then
do this with me the safe and sustainable
weight loss goal is between one to two
pounds per week the heavier you are the
quicker you will lose the weight
especially in the initial stage because
you have more body fat to burn the
lighter you are the slower you will lose
the weight because you have less body
fat to burn so what is your goal be
specific for instance I need to lose
thirty pounds
and now let's calculate realistically
how long will it take you to lose the
thirty pounds it will be between four to
five months
if you have more to lose it can be
overwhelming and sometimes seem almost
impossible what I like to work with is
short term goal so for instance instead
of focusing on I need to lose 60 pounds
just tell yourself I am going to work on
losing my weight on a monthly basis so
for the first month my target is to lose
eight pounds once you have achieved that
celebrate your success not with food and
then move on to month two my goal for
the second month is to lose eight pounds
once you have achieved that move on to
the third month little by little you
will be a step closer to your ultimate
goal
to lose weight you need to create an
energy deficit by consuming fewer
calories and to burn more calories
through physical activities to lose one
part of that you will need to burn an
estimate of 3500 calories and remember
this is just an estimate for instance if
your goal is to lose one pound per week
that you will need to create an energy
deficit of 500 calories per day this can
be 300 calories burn through exercising
and to reduce your food intake by 200
calories if your goal is to lose two
pounds per week especially if you're on
the heavier side then you will need to
create an energy deficit of 1000
calories per day again this can be from
activities 500 calories being burned and
to reduce your food intake by another
500 calories remember this is just an
estimate but it is a good benchmark to
kick start your weight loss journey
you can also click on this video here to
start calculating how many calories do
you need in order to lose the weight
take it step by step if you're someone
who is used to consuming a huge portion
it will not make it easy if you were to
cut your calories drastically so start
by making subtle changes for instance if
you are a woman start by consuming 1,700
to 1,800 calories as you progress with
your workout and as you start losing
weight then you can reduce your calories
by a further 150 to 200 calories
whatever you do do not consume below
1,200 calories because starving yourself
were only slowed down your metabolism
and it will cause your body to hold onto
precious fat instead of burning fats and
we do not want that now that you have
said your SMART goal let's look at the
two most important aspects to losing
weight which is your food intake and
physical activities let's start by
looking at food and nutrition eat
mindfully to lose the weight and to live
a healthier lifestyle you will need to
make
to your current eating habits losing
weight does not mean going on a diet
going on a diet
is usually short-term extreme changes
with lots of restrictions going on a
diet can help you to lose the weight but
it is usually only temporary
most people will pack on the weights and
some pack on even more weights once they
stop dieting so stop the mindset of
going on a diet instead focus on
permanent and manageable changes to your
food intake because at the end of the
day I want you to be able to sustain
your new weight most people tend to ask
me can you give me a list of food that I
can eat and I can't eat for me that is
just a lazy approach instead of being
given a list of food and following a
meal plan blindly it is more important
that you take the time to educate
yourself on food that is good for your
body a clean diet in short means eating
real food food in its purest form and
you know what's in the food for instance
do you know what's in a chicken breast
well chicken meat do you know what goes
into a chicken nugget a really small
percentage of chicken meat with fat
blood vessels nerve connective tissue
and ground bones so if you do not know
what goes into your food your best bet
is to stay away from it so how do I know
if I'm having a balanced diet - simply
put just think of having these four
groups of food in your meals whole grain
cups protein healthy fat and fruits all
vegetables aim to have this food in all
your meals and you will be feeding your
body with the best nutrients for an easy
way to eat just divide your plate into
three sections half of this should be
filled with vegetables quarter with
whole grain cups and another quarter
with protein by making these portion
changes and by eating more vegetables
you will be already reducing on your
calories nowadays our portion sizes are
much larger what we think is one portion
my
be two or three portions so please do
take the time to watch this video here
to see and understand what a portion
looked like because chances are you
might be overeating the next question is
how do I know how many calories is in my
food calories comes from protein fat
carbs and alcohol the easiest way is to
read the food label if there is an any
food label you can always search it up
on the internet and calculate the
calories based on the weight of your
food or you can use My Fitness Pal app
it is also worth noting that healthy
food does not necessarily mean low in
calories for instance peanut butter is
really good and healthy for you but it
is high in calories
due to the healthy fat content so you
should eat it but consume it in
moderation please do also take the time
to watch my other food and nutritional
videos because there will be a lot more
tips meal plan and recipe ideas for you
let's move on to step four which is to
choose your workout plan most people
tend to ask can I only eat healthy not
to do any workout and to lose weight
well the answer is yes but not by a
significant amount and it will take much
longer as well exercising will turn your
body into a fat-burning machine which
means more calories being burned in a
day and to help you to get better and
quicker results for instance if you were
to burn 400 calories in a workout
session it does not just stop there
exercising helps to build lean muscles
and the more lean muscles you have the
higher your metabolism will be which
means your body will burn fat more
efficiently even after your workout and
even on days when you are not working
out besides looking good and losing
weight exercising will help to boost
your health your energy and even your
happiness level so assuming that you are
a beginner and you
done any sort of workouts before
whatever you do will be tough initially
because your body is to adapting so keep
practicing the moves keep doing the
workout because you will only get
stronger and better it is very important
to focus on getting the right techniques
in order to target the right muscles so
don't rush through your workout and
focus on getting the right technique to
burn fat no matter from which body part
do you intend to lose for instance your
thighs hips belly or your arms it is
important to focus on total body
workouts we need to know that we cannot
spot reduce areas that we want so for
instance thinking that by doing two to
three hundred crunches a day you will
lose your belly fat that it's not true
at all
it is a combination of total body
workouts with ab workouts that will help
you to burn belly fat and to turn up
so start focusing on doing total body
workouts because that will help you with
your problematic areas and you will also
be toning up overall a combination of
cardio and strength training is the most
effective way to burn fat quick most of
my workout videos are based on strength
and cardio so you can kick-start your
workout plan by following my beginner
fat burning workout video and then move
on to my 90 days weight loss challenge
workout plan which is all available on
my website and can I just make it clear
that lifting weights and doing strength
training will not make you big nor bulky
in fact any kind of regular exercises
will not make you big nor bulky because
we ladies just do not have the hormones
to unless you were to train for a
competition or you intentionally want to
bulk up my workouts will not make you
big nor bulky at least I hope I do not
look big or bulky to you so start
lifting weights and start doing strength
training because it will only make you
look firmer so how long should your
workout session be and how many days
should you work
in a week that really comes down to your
personal schedule ideally I would say
five days a week between 45 to 60
minutes per session but if you really
can't do five days that's fine do three
days a week and if you really can't fit
45 minutes in that's right do shorter
sessions of maybe 15 minutes or even 30
minutes or even break your workouts up
so for instance 20 minutes in the
morning and another 20 minutes in the
evening the key here is to stay active
no matter how short your workout is you
will still burn calories and you will
still build lean muscles so for those of
you who really do not have the time to
do long workouts you can try some of my
short and effective workouts how many
calories should you aim to burn in a
workout session if you have a lot to
lose I would say between 4 to 500
calories per session if you have less to
lose then between 3 to 400 calories
calories varies individually from your
age your gender your height your weight
and more importantly your heart rate a
short intense 30-minute session will
help you to burn more calories in
comparison to a long moderate jogging
session hence my workouts are not meant
to be easy they are meant to challenge
your muscles to increase your heart rate
in order for you to see results so when
you are exercising on a scale of one to
10 one being really easy and 10 being
extremely out of breath you should be at
the level of 7 to 8 this will give you a
rough estimate of 8 to 10 calories being
burned per minute again remember calorie
burns varies individually and to get an
accurate measurement is to wear a heart
rate monitor you might be saying that
well I don't really like to go to the
gym and I don't like to do any home
exercises well that's fine choose
another activity that you enjoy whether
it's joining a dance club kickboxing or
even brisk walking choose an activity
that you know you will be able to
sustain and enjoy yourself while doing
it because at the end of the
you want to be looking forward to your
workout sessions instead of dragging
your way through the main point here is
to stay active on a daily basis even
making small changes like walking to
places walking up the stairs or standing
up more often will help you to burn an
additional of 150 to 200 calories in a
day the next concern is should I eat
back my workout calories while the
answer is yes and no we are encouraged
to eat back our workout calories because
after a workout session especially after
an intense workout you will need more
food for your body to repair and recover
so for instance if you were to burn 400
calories in a workout session it does
not necessarily mean that you have to
eat all the 400 calories back you might
find that eating an additional 200
calories is enough for you if I were to
eat back the 400 calories doesn't it
defeat the purpose of me trying to burn
the 400 calories while no exercising and
burning fat does not just stop there for
instance after an intense workout
session your body will keep burning fat
more efficiently for the next hour and
your metabolism will be increased for
the next 24 hours which means more fats
and more calories being burned so the
workout benefits continues what you
should not be practicing is the idea of
workout calories and food calories as
trade-off items for instance oh I've
been 400 calories I can have a donut now
No
not only are you really wasting your
time and effort you might be consuming
more than your workout calories in a
single donut don't work out because you
hit your body workout because you love
your body and you want to treat it right
step 5 is to keep track of yourself now
that you have your food and meal plan in
place keep track of your daily food and
physical activities self-awareness is
self motivation by keeping track of your
behavior you must avail yourself to
change by becoming more
countable keeping a food diary is the
first and most crucial step towards
weight management it is a great way to
assess your positive and negative habits
to look at areas that can be changed to
eat less to understand food calories and
to perhaps deal with emotional eating
and write everything down I mean every
single thing we tend to write our main
meals and we tend to forget about the
small nibbles you might have or even the
endless amount of coffee with milk you
might have in a day
almost everything that goes into your
mouth has calories so by writing a food
journal
you might find that it is those small
nibbles or the endless amount of coffee
with milk that is wrecking up the
additional 4 to 500 calories with this
information you can make smarter food
choices for your body and to understand
your emotion towards food so write
everything down immediately after a meal
because otherwise you will tend to
forget next step is to keep an activity
diary so write down what activity you
did how long for what was the intensity
how many calories did you burn and how
did you feel you can even be more
specific and record of the weights and
repetitions you did this is a good way
to keep track of your workouts and to
increase the weights and repetitions as
you get stronger your aim is to be able
to fill up your activity diary with 6
days of activities and one rest day in a
week so make a conscious effort to add
more activities into your days next is
to track and measure your weight loss
progress most women are obsessed over
the skill and the numbers really do
affect us basing your weight-loss
progress
solely on the skill is not accurate our
weight can fluctuate greatly from day to
day so do not measure yourself every day
in fact if you really have to only
measure yourself once a week and only
measure your weight loss progress once a
month because then you will see a much
more significant change which will keep
you
motivated do not make the skill your
only measurement of success so please do
watch my video here for other accurate
ways to measure your weight-loss success
step number six is to get support can
you lose weight on your own of course
you can but it can be challenging at
times it would be a benefit to you to
have a support network around you for
instance a workout buddy a family member
who choose for you
professionals like your personal trainer
or be part of an online community where
you can share your weight loss journey
with so for instance my youtube channel
here feel free to share your weight loss
journey ask questions and even support
each other that's what we are here for
it is very important for you to surround
yourself with positive and like-minded
people and to stay away from the
negative people who might directly or
indirectly sabotage your weight loss
goals to avoid this from happening let
us identify your indirect saboteurs
usually they will be family members or
close friends who might unintentionally
sabotage your plan for instance they
might buy you your favorite cake or
bring you to your favorite fast-food
restaurant
chances are they do not know your plan
to lose weight so speak to them and tell
them your intention to start losing
weight and to eat healthier understand
that you cannot expect them to change
their eating habits because of you but
both of you can work on a solution
together for instance if you do not have
control over your mom's cooking perhaps
you can suggest for her to cook more
vegetables to prepare a smaller portion
for you and to separate the sauce or
topping which is usually high in
calories this way you can exercise
portion control and to reduce all your
calories also like the note to stop
buying your favorite snacks and to buy
more fruits instead if you don't tell
your mom she wouldn't know if you were
to dine out with your partner or your
friend go to a place where you can make
healthier choices and both of you can
enjoy
at the same time don't be tempted to
have what they have make your own
choices know your portion and stick by
it some of you my face with direct
saboteurs people who intentionally want
to see you fail
my advice to you is to be selfish this
is your life your body and your goal if
they are not offering any support
instead they are making you feel
unworthy and to feel like a failure your
best bet is to stay away from them do
not waste your time trying to explain or
share your witness goals you do not owe
them any explanation and you should not
be guilty if you choose to avoid them
these people are usually jealous because
you're changing you're losing the weight
and you're getting in shape and they're
not so therefore to see you fail means
they can feel good about themselves and
their ego cashing out the support is
important but most importantly is self
support supporting yourself start from
your internal thoughts and emotion and
this has a huge impact on your progress
if you treat your body with love and
respect
you will naturally start feeding your
body with good food and give it the
workout it deserves
so start loving yourself by saying
positive words to yourself and reward
yourself not with food every time you
are a step closer to your goal the last
step is to take action now that you have
all the knowledge and tools you need you
are ready to go on this weight-loss
journey to a new you take one step at a
time one day at a time be consistent
with your workouts eat healthy most
times and I can assure you you will see
the result you deserve all success
stories come with willingness to change
determination taking action and to keep
trying and trying again when you fall
now that you are at the end of the video
grab a pen and paper if you
I ain't done it and start mapping out
your weight-loss journey start today not
tomorrow not next week or next month
give the gift of love back to yourself
this year all of us for new fitness food
and motivational videos please like
share and subscribe to my youtube
channel and website do follow me on
Facebook Instagram and Twitter to stay
connected with me thanks guys
you